I succeeded in having a great success
for an Italian movie in speaking in
Italian not in America are not in
English so it was really a big big thing
for for the industry even in Italy it
really gave me the chance to make people
believe in me as an actress and it was
something that was very important step
in my career and of course we did
opportunity like this wonderful story
because the story counts in a career of
an actor and to make a beautiful film I
mean acting and beautiful really as a
director like Vittorio De Sica which was
a great great teacher for me I owe I owe
a lot to him and a lot of my husband
which both they chose me for this
wonderful picture and they gave me a
great opportunity from then on then I
don't say it's easy but it's a little
easier to be able to have a path in your
career and to be able to move in movies
and in stories that you really feel very
close to you and maybe maybe who knows
being successful even though after that
I made another film that I liked very
much and it was called a special day
where my cello Mastriani was nominated
for an Oscar since we started in the in
the film that was called the too bad
she's bad the public accepts us like a
wonderful couple in the movies and since
then we made we work together for about
20 years and we made about 14 films
together and every one of them was very
successful Majella was somebody that I
will never forget was a wonderful
companion was a wonderful friend
was a great person and they're the films
that tells you that Italians are very I
think and I'm think I'm sure very
creative people not only in this world
but also in the fashion in anything they
put the hands on they are wonderful
people I'm really very proud to be
Italian you have to be always very close
to where you were born otherwise even
though you go to a school acting school
and everything like this which I never
did go but you have to follow your heart
and do whatever you think is it suits
you it moves you it enjoys you doing and
really had to follow your heart I mean
it's it's not easy sometimes because you
have to find you know to follow rules in
our business also but if you are
stubborn and you just want to do what
you think that you can give the best of
yourself sometimes you can succeed
you